now some more breaking news medical
sources have told Al Jazeera that 19
people have been wounded in an attack
targeting the mayor's office in
somalia's capital Mogadishu al-shabaab
Fighters have claimed responsibility for
the attack on the mayoral offices which
have now been cordoned off Fighters
stormed the building shortly after the
explosion where confrontations are
ongoing
has more from Mogadishu
there were two explosions targeting the
Gate of the municipality building which
was then Stoned by armed members of
al-shabab armed group a spokesman for
al-shabab have confirmed they were
responsible for the attack
Somali government is yet to comment on
the incident Witnesses say security
forces have been able to evacuate
employees from the building they have
stopped people from approaching the area
which is completely cordoned off as
confrontations are ongoing the attack
comes in the context of the war between
the Somali government and al-shabab and
everyone knows very well that al-shabab
has been subjected to military campaigns
in many of the central regions of
Somalia which has led to the armed group
losing its control over several regions
however al-shabab despite these losses
didn't stop launching attacks against
the government forces the last of which
was on Friday when the galat base was
attacked where both sides suffered big
losses